(keyboard music)
- I know that I have a
lot of missed connections
but I just feel like this one
was really something special.
I just wanna make sure
that this draft is right.
- Just speak from the heart.
You're always good at that.
- [Abbi] I'm just taking him
through what exactly happened.
We met at Lush over
the boysenberry soap,
I gotta make sure
that's spelled right,
I'm gonna ital that.
And then we both
reached for the same bar
and then I said 'you take it'
and then he said 'are you OK?'
and I realized actually
hadn't said anything
cuz it was like in my mind
and I think he would
know that if I wrote it.
- Aw.
- Are you paying attention
to what I'm saying?
- I've never
experienced this before.
- What are you doing, dude?
Ew! What is that?
- I think it's a bedbug
bite or something.
- Oh my god.
- It's like an ant's meatball.
- Ilana, I think it's a pimple.
- [Ilana] Would you
help me purge it?
It like really hurts.
- On here?
- I need your help.
I'm lost in the woods
here, cystic bacne woods.
- Alright. Let's just do it.
- Horizontal or
vertical squeeze?
- I'd say... horizontal?
- [Ilana] Okay, one outta ten,
how hard should I squeeze it?
- I would say ten.
- Okay, ready?
(grunt and squirt)
Oh! Ow! Ah! Ho!
I feel like I just
got your screen dirty.
- Why is this part of my day?